CHECK IT OUT.
WE ARE GOING TO WEIGH IN ON IT
LATER IN THE SHOW.
THE RETURN OF BARACK OBAMA.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'
WATERS WORDS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
RELATIVELY QUIET SINCE LEAVING
OFFICE BUT POPPED UP?
SOUTH AFRICA.
>> UNFORTUNATELY TOO MUCH OF
POLITICS TODAY SEEMS TO REJECT
VERY CONCEPT OF OBJECTIVE TRUTH.
PEOPLE JUST MAKE STUFF UP.
WE SEE THE UTTER LOSS OF SHAME
AMONG POLITICAL LEADERS WHERE
THEY ARE CAUGHT IN A LIE AND
THEY DOUBLE DOWN AND LIE SOME
MORE.
JESSE: WE KNOW HE'S CALLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP A LIAR.
THER PRESIDENT OBAMA, HAVE YOU
NO SHAME?
>> IF YOU LIKE YOUR DOCTOR YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP YOUR DOCTOR
PERIOD.
IF YOU HAVE LIKE YOUR HEALTHCARE
PLAN, YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
HEALTHCARE PLAN PERIOD.
THERE IS NO SPYING ON AMERICANS.
WE DON'T HAVE A DOMESTIC SPYING
PROGRAM.
>> A HANDGUN AND CLIPS IS EASIER
TRUTH.
BUT SOME ARE SMOOTHER THAN
OTHERS.
BARACK, YOU LIED.
BUT THE MEDIA COVERED UP YOURS.
SPEAK OF THE PRESS.
>> THE PRETHE FREE PRESS IS
UNDER ATTACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN'T ATTACK
THE PRESS AS MUCH AS TRUMP DOES.
HE DIDN'T NEED TO.
90% OF THE MEDIA WAS ON HIS
SIDE.
AND THERE HAS BEEN MORE FAKE
NEWS ABOUT TRUMP IN ONE YEAR
LET THAT SINK IN.
A.P. AND FOX NEWS.
CONSTANTLY ATTACKED.
THE ESPIONAGE ACT, HE USE I'D IT
ALMOST MORE THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT COMBINED TO GO AFTER
REPORTERS AND LEAKERS.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID
IT WAS THE LEAST TRANSPARENT
ADMINISTRATION OF ALL TIMES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD HIS
AUDIENCE IN AFRICA, WE ARE
LIVING IN STRANGE TIMES.
>> THEY ARE STRANGE.
AND THEY ARE UNCERTAIN.
BUT EACH DAY'S NEWS CYCLES
BRINGING MORE HEAD-SPINNING AND
DISTURBING HEADLINES.
YOUR ADMINISTRATION.
REMEMBER OUR PRESIDENT BOWS TO
FOREIGN LEADERS?
RACIAL RIOTS ALL OVER STREETS
TACK AMERICA.
A RASH OF DOMESTIC TERROR
ATTACKS, A WOMAN SHOT DEAD BY A
DEPORTED ILLEGAL ALIEN FELON.
REMEMBER THE PRESIDENT LAUGHING
AND FIST BUMPING AFTER AN
AMERICAN WAS BEHEADED?
HERITAGE WITHOUT DENIGRATING
THOSE OF A DIFFERENT HERITAGE.
JESSE: I GUESS OBAMA DOESN'T
AND RUN BY WHITE PEOPLE.
HE TAUGHT ME JESUS DID HOW TO
LOVE MY ENEMIES.
JESUS TOLD ME HOW TO LOVE THE
HELL OUT OF MY ENEMIES.
JESSE: BARACK OBAMA WAS MARRIED
OBAMA WITH FARAKAN.
TOTAL HYPOCRISY WHICH LEAVES US
TO THIS.
>> SO MANY [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> IT'S ENOUGH.
JESSE: HERE IS BARACK OBAMA
ENJOYING A TROPICAL TRIP ON
BILLIONAIRE, RICH BRANSON'S
WORLD CLASS SQUAT.
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOTICE HOW IT HAS A WALL AROUND
IT FOR SECURITY.
I THOUGHT WALLS WERE RACIST.
I GUESS NOT.
I GUESS PRESIDENT OBAMA SHOULD
TAKE ADVICE FROM ANOTHER
PRESIDENT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD FOR